Direct democracy is when all citizens vote on all decisions
rather than the representatives voting on our behalf.
The main problem is it demands too much time and effort.
Parliament make hundreds of decisions every year.
People would have to read every draft Bill,
research every topic, the advantages and disadvantages,
consider the consequences for hundreds of issues every year.
There will be no end to this process,
and there will be a new topic almost every single day.
In voluntary voting systems,
most people would not participate,
but a select number of people would be engaged
and they would make all of our choices for us.
We would just replace one set of problems
with a different set of problems.
If our direct democracy was a compulsory system,
people would become exhausted.
They would not have time for their regular jobs,
family obligations or leisure activities.
So the main problem of direct democracy
is that it would demand too much time and effort.
It wouldn't work if it were under a voluntary voting system,
and it would just be a massive burden
if it were in a compulsory voting system.